ultimately when a finance year or
distributor is saying yes to you as a
screenwriter they're not just saying yes
to your idea and your craftsmanship and
your talent what they're really saying
yes to
is what's the difference between a
general meeting and a pitch meeting ah
well a general meeting is just a pure
let's get to know each other see if
there's chemistry and I if I'm an
executive or on the producing side I'm
I'm looking to like mine some territory
so I get to know you better without
making a commitment to you from the
artist side it's like let me share as
much as I possibly can about who I am in
case an opportunity arises that might be
right so there isn't a specific job
opening or
opportunity that is immediately
available so the general meeting is like
okay let's just get to know each other
and then or sometimes they call like a
meet and
greet but you're going to someone's
office yeah or having a cup of coffee
somewhere or even a zoom now uh yeah do
you think most screenwriters understand
what happens in general
meetings
um that's a that's another great
question I'm not I feel like
um I I don't know the answer to that
question I was just I immediately went
to like agents and managers where agents
are too busy to explain the distinctions
between oh you're going in for an
interview versus like a general or and
greet where I feel like managers if if
an artist has a manager then it's like
so important to be able to explain the
difference and um I'm involved with some
different organizations and I feel like
um you know it's like the elevator pitch
or just like what's your personal story
I'm I and I do this in my coaching work
as well like let's make certain that
you've got your personal story so
whether you're in a meet and greet a
general or a job interview because it
almost always inevitably comes up of
like like oh tell me about yourself and
then it's like H hum hum it's like oh no
you've got this thing in your back
pocket where you can say in like a
minute minute and a half this is who I
am and I always find it interesting
nowadays that people are very
transparent about whatever sort of
challenges they faced as part of their
pitch yes being Generation X I think we
just that wasn't part of the curriculum
then we were supposed to be perfect and
we now people oh yeah I'm bipolar I'm on
the Spectrum here and and everybody's
okay with it and in some ways that's
refreshing do you tell people to sort of
rein in some of the stuff save that for
later maybe that'll come out with your
screenplay um it's it's so um it really
depends on the individual and their
relationship with the information that
they could potentially divulge so um so
I'm obviously sharing a lot of personal
information with you about myself but
I've worked on that so I don't have like
shame around it I'm I'm comfortable with
it but then there are other people who
for example there's someone I'm thinking
about who is recently discovered that
they're neurod Divergent and so they're
really grappling with that diagnosis and
so I would never advocate for that
person to walk into an interview or even
a meet and greet and and share that
information because they're still
figuring out their relationship with it
where um there's a wonderful writer that
I've worked with um who's blind and he
talks very openly and I think he's he's
actually secured um
opportunities um as a writer because of
being blind and the way that he talks
about it and the things like the
challenges that he's had to overcome the
things that he's done where it's like oh
my gosh this person is really
interesting and can add a lot to this
project because of uh his relationship
with being blind and also he wasn't born
blind it was something that happened to
him later in life and so he he he tells
a very compelling story about that
experience so yeah just in a nutshell I
think it depends on the person's
relationship with what they're about to
divulge whether it's my parents divorce
or
uh yeah abuse or etc etc that it all
depends how much pitching should a
screenwriter do in a general meeting oh
I'd say very little I think you really
have to read the room and and really get
a sense if the conversation is leading
up to a pitch I I feel like in and I
would say actually really not pitching
and it's if it's more like oh you're
interested in Thrillers I'd love to come
back and Pitch you this idea and they
like do the oneliner but don't actually
pitch in the room but just tea up coming
back to pitch and so maybe that too not
reading the room can hurt you as well
yes yeah yeah it's
uh uh I think listening is one of the
most important tools to have and it's
also one of the most difficult to master
because you're going into a meeting or a
job interview and it's like it's really
hard to like listen to the other person
because it's like oh I'm trying to
remember my personal story I'm trying to
remember my talking points it's like oh
but if you're able to just like breathe
and like listen to the energy of the
person it allows you to create Rapport
and connection that will will help
service the overall goal of like okay is
this a match here should we work
together and is there more opportunity
to
pursue yeah that's very difficult when
you're nervous yes and want to impress
yes very much CU it's almost like you
don't hear the other person you're just
like okay then my next thing is this and
then right yeah and then you appear
desperate on unfortunately yeah why do
Executives have General
meetings oh well I feel like the the
best Executives the best producers are
constantly like getting to know people
because like for me as an executive
former executive and now as a producer
it's my um uh it's when an opportunity
comes up it's like my job to say oh here
are the 10 or 12 best candidates for
that opportunity and the only way that
I'm really going to know that is if I've
read people and if I've met with them
because like you might be really great
on paper and then I meet with you and
then I discover that what sets you up
for success is actually not how let's
say you know the producer likes to work
or there's a piece of Ip but it's going
to require the writer to have a
relationship with that person who holds
the life rights or that actual
individual and so I'm really looking to
see how do I build this team and so
having General meetings gives me a low
stress like low stakes opportunity to
get to know you at your best uh and
start to develop this relationship and
then also again as like as an executive
or as a producer I want to build a
relationship with you because um when I
do have the right project for you and
then you're considering you know seven
other things I want to be like hey we've
met a couple times and you know I've
been tracking you and it's like it's
like I want to convince you to say yes
to me as opposed to you getting this
opportunity out of the blue how many
executives are present at pitch
meetings oh um in my experience it's at
least
two and it's very rare that I see one
executive I'm thinking about this from
like on the streaming broadcast network
side um if you're and you're speaking
specifically about Executives but if
you're pitching to producers that it
might just be the one producer but
usually they like to have at least two
people in the meeting to really be able
to have someone to you know bounce
thoughts and ideas off of after the
meeting how does an executive evaluate a
great story yeah um it's from a couple
of it really depends on the situation so
uh so for example I'm actually going to
go back to the idea of like if this is a
pitch for a new idea let's say it's um
whether it's a film or a TV series of
what's the creative mandate does it
check off those boxes just in terms of
of concept and then and then looking at
okay is a story welld developed do I
understand the world do I understand the
characters do I understand the emotional
trajectory um do I understand how the
story is is building and arcing um and
then let's say it's a it's a TV series
and I'm a producer I'm an executive and
so it's like okay here's the story idea
for episode three and and so and again
it just sort of depends on is this um a
procedural is it um is it a mystery is
it a soap opera and so I'm looking at
the story from the lens of of the
genre
and uh and so if it's a procedural
that's a standalone I'm looking at the
story to say okay do you have a strong
hook in that tease that's going to grab
the audience set up what the um you know
what the crime is that sense of mystery
and then I'm really looking at the ACT
breaks and if I'm at a broadcast network
I'm looking to see oh are the ACT breaks
strong enough that'll help you know
drive people past the commercial break
uh if I'm at a
streamer I'm not worried about
commercial breaks at all well that's
sort of changing now and so again it
sort of depends on the circumstance but
let's say it's a it's a commercial free
streamer so then I'm looking at um at
the story from a different perspective
let's say it's a um it's a soap opera
and so then I'm like okay how how are
you ending that story to drive people to
the next
episode uh but I'm always like looking
at how is the story set up within that
particular episode and how is it going
to Arc over the course of those you know
50 minutes the 55 minutes so uh so we
keep the audience engaged for the entire
time and coming back for the next
one that was a really like Fast great I
feel like I could have gone into more
specific depth but it so depends on the
circumstance how much persuasion does it
take for a screenwriter to convince
Executives to buy their
screenplay um I think about it
specifically from a screen writers
perspective from a couple different
places one is do they have a portfolio
of work
that
establishes their ability their craft
their point of view and then specific to
the pitch itself is it a well-developed
pitch that they can convey in you know
25 to 30 minutes um that establishes the
characters the world the story etc etc
but then there's a third component
that's really critical from a persuasion
perspective which is really about what's
the package because ultimately when a
financier or distributor is saying yes
to you as a screenwriter they're not
just saying yes to your idea and your
craftsmanship and your talent what
they're really saying yes to is I'm
about to invest hundreds of thousands
potentially millions of dollars
potentially tens of millions of dollars
into what you're about to create are you
the person that's going to be able to
get that across the Finish Line are you
going to be able to get me a strong
enough draft that can attach talent in
some form and so the persuasion
component may also include from that
third bucket that you've got a strong
producer that in addition to your
credentials what have you assembled as
part of your team to say and please
forgive me for saying this in this way
that you're worthy of this investment
what final advice do you have for
screenwriters and preparing their
pitch this is a reflection of my values
which is um to prepare which I know
sounds crazy but it means something
different to everyone which is a running
theme of our
conversation but um you C even if it's
to a producer don't don't ever go in
half ass it's like do your homework it's
like develop your characters develop
your world develop your story and then
overwrite it and then make it concise
because you want to I my experience with
screenwriters with writers is that
you've worked so hard on creating your
story and you want everybody to know
everything and it actually doesn't serve
you it's better to be concise and to
have a summary that hits key moments
versus telling everything in
detail Executives they are hearing you
know potentially several pitches in
every day and they just start to get
fatigued and they also know what they're
looking for and so you want to really
understand from their perspective what
their day is like so you can speak to
their needs solve their
problems okay how how is a
perfectionist becoming too prepared or
is that not something that to worry
about but is there a way that a
perfectionist could maybe squeeze the
life out of it and it turns out they're
they're sabotaging themselves yes
absolutely I think about pitches and I
think about um screenplays as pastry
dough that if you touch it too much it
starts to lose its flakiness and it's
it's butteriness and so um so yeah you
can overwork it so it loses its magic um
so I'm going to contradict myself to say
when you do finally have that meeting
and you may be feeling overprepared or
underprepared Tara Linsky it Tara Linsky
was um a figure skater and she won the
gold I want to say she was either 12 or
14 years old she came off the ice the
inter the people interview her and they
like how did you do it t and she's like
I've been preparing for this moment my
entire life and she had this like high
squeaky voice because she was so young
and she's like I just decided to go out
there and have fun and so I would say
the same thing of whether you feel
overprepared or underprepared when you
have that meeting just go in have fun
with it there's nothing more that you
can do in the 11th hour that's going to
change the you know the outcome so just
go in with and have fun and share that
story from a PL that place where you
created it which was
passion